hello hello welcome to another Gamespot
live stream uh today we're going to do
the OverWatch Halloween special uh
Halloween event I'm joined by Joey
what's up Joey uh you're a big Avid
OverWatch fan I've kind of tapered off a
little bit but I always enjoy having fun
um with these events and also the new
skins and emotes so we're pretty much
going to go in and check those out uh
there is a new bra mode the brawl mode
is essentially like kind of like a horde
mode in a way or like a defending kind
of like if you ever played the old man
vs machine mode from TF2 it's basically
like that so you have all the the NPCs
uh sweet once you show me some skins
while you're talking okay and stuff
because I know you've been looking at
some of the stuff so oh yeah that's what
everyone cares about right we're also
opening crate sorry to cut you off yeah
but we're gonna open crates and stuff so
I think there are about 12 new costumes
yeah this is the first one Anna's hmm
all right got a little spider web on it
see
we got bastions which is whoops
not as great
it's hard to yeah okay rip he's got a
little Raven on it instead of the yeah
let's see hanzo's which is basically him
just being kind of dead hey zombie mode
that's fine with me
junkrats is probably the best one next
to uh roadhogs
yeah
look at that that's pretty sweet
actually
let's see who else was it Mercy's that's
pretty good I think
oh yeah it's that one okay yeah the
which one's pretty good best part though
that's that's pretty sweet that's pretty
sweet
um Mars also just kind of possessed dead
oh that's pretty cool though but it's
got that it's got the heat like the The
Fog yeah the glue that's pretty that's
pretty cool like I don't I didn't see
too much of that on any other oh did
Reaper finally get anyone this is good
this is good oh yeah pumpkin head dude
he's got the he's got the candle wax on
his gun too I need that in my life too
bad today for once I'm not gonna be
opening the crates uh we're gonna open
50 later on Joey's account we're gonna
kind of let the uh chats settle in a bit
uh you know oh wow Reinhardt always gets
good ones I swear man I swear he always
gets really good ones he always gets
really good ones like even the like the
last update yeah both of those are
amazing yeah they're just pushing a lot
of Reinhardt skins on us
yeah who else oh roadhogs is awesome I
want this too Frankenstein oh that belly
button weight thing really gross you
look at the back though that's awesome
there's also wind poses right you said
well we'll go through the Skins first
and then we'll go see also has a new gun
pretty cool looking yeah
I mean they do an amazing job granted
it's kind of a money grab but you know
true hey it's okay oh that that's at
least like a uh just an epic one that's
okay that's all right I assume these are
just like the uh the summer skins where
you won't be able to just outright buy
them with gold at least until later is
it late did they ever open up for gold
or no they never do okay
so you either want some pay to look good
or uh you know maybe you don't
because I still don't have
um Japan Genji and I probably never will
until the next four years four years
down the line maybe you might uh I have
like everything else oh there's a
Zenyatta yeah oh man they're really
getting me okay okay it's okay yeah it's
all right it's all right he does have
like the black like the spine yeah and
the and the head was a little bit
different it's kind of yeah it's
distressed
um and then every character also has a
new uh wind pose every character every
single character and okay it's they're
mostly the same it's basically just a
tombstone with their hand or whatever
else sticking out okay oh so it's kind
of like that Olympic thing again with
the gold medal right yeah yeah yeah okay
so some of them are pretty good some of
them are just kind of meh yeah
this one's uh this one's okay there's
his head okay
let's see so Diva has a pose at least
she doesn't have she's like Deuces piece
you know
um oh you got your band can't you yeah I
got Japan
oh that's sick though that's awesome
dude I need that
let's see what's hanzo's
okay yeah it's what you would imagine
yeah
does a new map come out uh I don't think
there's a new map it's just a new brawl
guys we'll check it out in a second
looks pretty cool it's got some some
vocals to it at least his gun still
works yeah someone's gonna steal that at
some point junkrats is it's just his leg
his Peg Leg some traps around there
that's interesting though that was like
um that the wheel was uh your based on
your skin though yeah okay so it always
changes yeah yeah
let's reach for the sky yeah
oh
her companion will never leave her
this is live for everyone right now you
can download it uh Joey was actually
able to get in at like 10 30. uh we
thought it was at 11
um but you know the new brawl mode is
playable uh you just join up with three
other people there's only four Heroes
you can pick
um and yeah we're just checking out some
of the new scans the wind poses
um we're gonna play the new mode
probably like twice maybe and then we'll
start opening crates we have 50 crates
oh that's kind of cool yeah that's kind
of that's kind of dark though of course
well it's Reaper I'm never dead
um
um okay the ax all right and I guess for
everyone who's coming in probably
wondering the same question no Sombra is
not out yet yeah come on it's BlizzCon
let's be real here they need to save
something for BlizzCon I'm I'm like
almost willing to bet it's Sombra the
new and a new map
um maybe a little bit more but I I
wouldn't doubt it's it's that
um but yeah
it's crazy though they keep doing all
these events I'm sure there's gonna be a
Christmas event too yeah um
is that Activision thing man oh it's
cool that she's got her uh the turrets
yeah because like even Destiny started
to kind of do
um events around like themed events so
there would probably be a Halloween one
yeah and then a Christmas one great way
to stay topical yeah look at this tire
iron up there you can buy the new skins
and victory poses with coins but there
are three times I don't know if you can
but maybe you can be poses yeah they're
225 okay so they're just three times the
cost is what someone said but as far as
the the new skins oh man because it did
say 3000 on it and you just don't have 3
000. um widowmakers legs
dangling
um I mean we could check later on my
account because I think I have 3 000
um
coins uh we did show some of the weapons
earlier so we'll probably get back to
that later
um because we already showed it uh you
can either kind of scrub back on the DVR
on the uh
YouTubes or the Gamespot uh again I am
reading chat so I'll try to answer your
questions to the best of your ability
I'm not sure if it's on Console yet
because we are playing on PC
um so sorry about that folks but someone
probably can confirm for you soon it's
not a very big patch though okay like a
couple gigs so you can buy them okay if
you have enough that's good that's fair
yeah it's triple the cost though yeah
that's the only thing that's not bad uh
but I can only afford one skin
all right let's go play a game let's go
check that out that's a pretty sweet
this is a nice splash screen right here
got the Halloween Terror yep
so junkenstein's Revenge so the brawl
details you can only play as Anna Hanzo
McCree and Soldier
okay interesting yeah let's do this yep
hopefully we'll find a game
you know what I'm really disappointed
about what's that the the somber leak
actually
in that they spent so many weeks so many
months like hyping it up and making it
into such a mystery and then for it to
just be
found out from random screenshots yeah
that happens I mean technically
technically we've we in our own
OverWatch series for like one frame on a
monitor you see someone that you thought
was like maybe Anna or like a Widowmaker
skin but it's probably Sombra oh God
maybe uh you know the Reddit cops can go
look that up but uh it does I mean like
it all it's it's always tough with leaks
um you know every company tries to do
their best to hide them but you know it
is the internet unless of course we'll
let this play a little bit
where the lord of the castle has called
for Heroes to come to his Aid and defend
him against the Mad Dr junkenstein our
team is about to begin
good luck finding a game it's impossible
it turns out
[Music]
all right bring it back down a little
bit now you're mentioning you would
literally you would have loved to have
played that mode in all black yeah I
know that would have been so cool all
right see what's going on here
so what was that like wave one yeah I
guess so oh there's more okay let's see
down here you can see in the top left
there's a new uh there's a new UI pop-up
I guess that's the uh the contribution
to the match that I've made I'm only at
uh those are your super actually oh
really oh no yeah it is okay to try to
help tell your teammates like you know
super like if you have super or not are
they keeping that up for like I have no
idea we can check later for like also
like just normal matches too
I doubt it's a normal matches though
oh so if they hit your door the the door
you're supposed to protect You're Gonna
Lose
um like life points or whatever at the
top and I'm sure probably different
minions at some point chemicals
electricity and whatnot seems like
there's what three spawn points right
now
another reason
right there's something no there's no
Jesus came
here
I like how the narration with Reinhardt
there
that's too much oh watch out there's a
rip Tire oh [__]
good one good one good save
because we've seen like maybe three
enemy types oh that guy's got range yeah
you gotta kill that guy so this is um
it's almost like a zombarter I guess
that guys those guys are like the melee
grunt guys
and then you got the random like junk
junkrats higher it's trying to blow up
the door
so you gotta hold out for another four
minutes and 50 seconds
you can see like everyone on the you can
tell everyone's just hoarding their uh
just in case oh my God sweet
oh he's he's a boss oh
stun him oh
he's dead okay good but uh watch out
your door is gonna be for the last time
I bet he comes back
of course
oh no the player Q has started we got
lucky again Joey oh really yeah it
always happens somehow we we like barely
know that it's out and then we're just
like oh God we gotta get on and then we
just want to keep getting right yeah
just at the right time have we opened
boxes we have not yet uh we're saving
that for probably like Midway this
stream try to build up the viewership a
little bit I'll be honest um
have more people see the the uh pains or
the the gains the happiness or the
sadness where does it come from
it's middle
what were your favorite skins um or like
what skins do you think you want to get
from the boxes the box is definitely the
junkrats yeah I play them more than
anyone else you would you scrub
filthy junk rats man filthy well he is
kind of dirty yeah he doesn't you don't
really have to aim you're just anyways I
won't get into that
um the mercy one even though I don't
really play her just to have that I love
that broomstick oh yeah the mercy oh
fire Hood in the hole down
[Music]
um we can show some of the skins and the
weapon skins later once we get out of
the match we kind of already did that uh
so if you want to just scrub back for a
second to see those go ahead and Joey
kind of showed most of them I don't know
if you went through all the weapons but
you went through some of the cooler ones
probably don't want to be over there
yeah
I want to use my old account
oh he's gonna review oh you think it's
roadhog
oh man
I wonder can I kill him if I do that
he said he got a uh
he got the prank or the junkrat skin and
oh my God uh the reaper play the game in
one uh box that's pretty good man I hope
we have good luck for two of this luck
last time when I did the summer games I
got really bad luck my first 50 and then
my second 50 were like pretty good
this guy is not going down the tank what
do you expect except
technically
kind of like a hybrid tank yeah
but you know it's like a PVE thing here
right now right so they can do whatever
they want I think it's cool I think it's
cool to see some of this like something
different not necessarily not always
within like the same setting yeah use
the characters for other game modes like
this is technically this is like the
first real different game mode that
they've ever had outside of like the
Lucio ball which is kind of like still
within the confines of the game which is
still cool it's like that rocket league
in a way but this is definitely
um oh I think he might be the boss
well there's a minute 45 left uh you
guys only have one star out of four so I
don't know if that means you're doing
okay or bad or what
oh yeah fast throwing stuff oh he's
shooting his uh grenades I guess
almost there that two though okay nice
done
not good
nice punch the reaper in the face
yeah the Halloween update is out guys uh
go ahead and play uh you can play it
just download it
um I haven't got confirmation on the
consoles yet but uh PC is definitely out
but I wouldn't be shocked if it's out on
Console soon because they've been trying
to do a lot more of those uh
simultaneous releases do you see the
Hanzo that's up top on the door where is
he he's on the door or like on a little
ledge within the door
oh watch out
it's cool that it's just like totally
avoids everything and just goes for the
door oh it doesn't yeah
oh Reaper's back
told you the reaper always comes back
man
oh he's taking big damage this time
though
I want to see more console is out now
thank you for the update there Dark One
X uh I want to see more of these kind of
modes
um because I know a lot of people enjoy
the base game the competitive playing
and free play but it'd be cool to add
more of these kind of like player versus
something mode anything single or not
even single player but just PVE yeah
something where you don't necessarily
need to be stressed about it for like 20
minutes at a time
oh final battle oh
the witch
oh she reads oh my god oh no
nice
oh no what does that even mean though
you guys 10 seconds
[Music]
uh you better hope your teammates can
live too too down right now she's
healing though this is not good you guys
gotta go this is just like OverWatch man
you gotta go for the Healer you can't be
going for the tank
if you go for the tanks all day you're
just gonna lose
hi mooner
oh she's running yeah that's what she's
supposed to do man
that's what a good Mercy would do
I don't think you're gonna kill him with
her pocket healing oh my God and he just
uses all
these there you go you just gotta come
on come on
[Music]
ah just like a competitive match exactly
what happens every time
oh my God okay you're back you're back
just go uh
did they kill her
okay nice heal by the uh Anna I think I
got rid of the witch which is good
yeah all right
guys
sweet all right what do you get maybe
you get a
that's pretty cool I like it
wonder if you get a box for doing this
oh there's still plays in the game yeah
got to
mowing down zombies
[Music]
because he saved the tire
all right sure
the play of the game really was when he
got hooked by the uh I got 59 accuracy
at least that's good
all right let's see what you get maybe I
wonder if you get a reward on level oh
perfect timing for a level maybe oh we
got another one do you think do you
think you get a new box though probably
that's what they did in the uh Olympic
Games right yeah
leave that one and
let's see if you did get a 51 one oh you
did okay so when you level up you do get
a new crate
um why don't you show those epic weapons
really quick
and then we'll
they want to see some skin so we'll show
some skins then we'll um maybe we'll
open like 25
no we should probably just open all of
them do them all at one time yeah we
should probably do it all at one time
the jack-o-lantern phase I'm just really
trying to milk you guys that's all milk
it for everything
it's out on Console I've got it that
says bad YouTuber uh yeah so if you guys
want to play it's out I wouldn't mind if
you guys kept the stream open too but
you know if you got to play you gotta
play understandable
um there's a junkrat
pretty good pretty good
his is all right like I don't I really
hope you don't get that one
foreign
and like how many people play Bastion
not as much as they used to hanzo's I
like that one I mean like if you play
Hanzo I think it'd be pretty cool to
have that one because it kind of you
know got that is this bow any different
um just different color I think I don't
think it's no it's just red color yeah I
mean it's not usually it's the Epic
skins that have the different or sorry
the legendary skins that have the
different weapons like what was his what
was how different was his weapon it's
pretty different like the Tesla Wheels
already like pretty cool yeah and then
the the gun is like
or whatever compared to like it's got a
little like this one right here yeah
yeah it's just kind of cool to see him
like not like a criminal and like as a
scientist I guess it's probably the best
probably the best one of the vlot um I
think the roadhog one's pretty sick too
like this is cool because of the broom
yeah but it's it's still kind of similar
to her other skins mine is like the Hat
I guess you know it's not like that
difference
yeah because like the wings and stuff
like that that's like the Imp wings are
just different color and I don't know
the shoes I guess yeah but they're
killing it it's legendary so it'll still
it's not the same Rarity as all the
other good ones
hers is just like a I think that's cool
though because she's got the she's got
the fog I think that's even even the
wings are kind of like this little nice
subtle touches for sure what's her
weapon look like weapons it's pretty
close yeah
yeah I wish that Dad had fog too yeah
or like the the rocket the Rockets
that's yeah it's also purple oh yeah
here we go
he was one of the better ones too I feel
like it makes salmon the brawl too it
makes sense though because like based on
themes you can pick certain characters
to like you know they're gonna look good
yeah
um like May will probably get a skin uh
for Christmas I I have to imagine I
can't I have to imagine there's no way
that she's not that is so cool though
like oh yeah look at that yeah I just
he's got the fog too but his glowing
head is probably like the best part I
think this weapons pretty similar
um subtle touches yeah we'll open the
boxes we're just gonna go through these
skins and and whatnot and then we'll go
through the boxes and then we'll
probably play another match or whatever
style belt buckle here
I like the Tesla coils or whatever those
are pretty cool too
his hook wasn't different right I know
it is slightly different oh okay cool
instead of muddied like that okay
so oh it's okay yeah it's like it's it's
slightly different I like it
you can buy yeah you can buy all the
Skins it's just three times the cost it
seems like actually I don't know though
it's locked oh but maybe it's locked
because you don't have enough gold I
don't have enough gold okay
yeah soldiers that's
it's pretty pedestrian like I mean yeah
the Epic ones aren't going to have too
much Flair right yeah
symmetras is okay
yeah she's got the stockings at least
the like bats or whatever and then her
uh her guns and then her teleporters
also the red color oh man too bad it's
not like like the teleporter itself
wasn't like black or something like a
black portal that'd be sick is it live
on Console Master Joda says it is or
asking rather are there new sprays I
would imagine so they're gonna RNG you
out man they're gonna find a way to RNG
you out what I didn't like actually was
opening the crates and then getting the
old skins because I got oh yeah I was
getting legendaries but then they were
like the old legendaries I was like dude
I just want the Olympic game not even
that they all they can also get you can
also get duplicates of the old ones yeah
exactly instead of the new new ones yeah
at least you'll get gold I guess but
like these new skins are so expensive
it's like man
uh someone making the comment that Andre
Lewis I think symmetra looks like Morgan
a little bit the color scheme definitely
I think so like Morgan from darkstalkers
a little bit but Morgan has like that
teal and pink yeah yeah so much red
yeah let me just check how much were
they three thousand or seven it's three
thousand for the uh new epic or the new
legendary look at the numbers
let's just pray that they're going to be
all right on the chest we're gonna open
the boxes he's got 51 This Is The Moment
of Truth this is the moment of truth I
I'm gonna leave our pip up for his
reaction and or mine it doesn't won't
hurt me as much because it's not my
actual crates but uh here we go
good luck to you sir
legendary already
gold of course oh that's a new spray
oh yeah
the big time fails
we got a nice poor viewer remote
laughing one
next
open loot box uh yeah
I like that animation yeah nothing oh
the there's new icons as well of course
like I said they're gonna RNG you out
let's keep it going
man
sadness yeah
it hurts more because we did get a
legendary and I feel like it's like one
in like 10. well they they start you off
with one then they're like yeah yeah
keep going
yep eyeball
who's that far oh it's just anyone
okay we got a chance okay you got you
got one something we've got a background
to it too yeah they didn't have that
before all right so we got a soldier
skin it's all right
not necessarily one that that Joey
wanted but maybe by the time we're done
opening boxes you'll have 3 000 you can
just buy the jungle this one hopefully I
like this candy that they have here
spill out oh
another one back to back back to back
and you play honor right yeah let's keep
it going good we're on a mini roll here
come on come on come on oh wow three in
a row it's it's so far been better than
I like that young uh is that hanza or
Genji that's Hanzo that's pretty cool
um so three in a row pretty good doing
all right
we're doing okay right now three epics
in a row
come on
gold is that him or highlight intro nah
it's old yeah it's pretty cool though
it's just really hard to get play of the
game yeah all his highlight intros are
really sick though yeah
agreed
it's a dud oh another like young zarya
they all have like the Cutie version of
them with the the candy I guess
I imagine this has to be fun for like
the art team and stuff too over at
blizzard and whatnot they got to make
new skins and yeah I mean just imagine
how boring it would be if they just need
to support like the regular yeah like no
no cool events like this nothing
I think holiday themed I'm Pac-Man says
all I want is junkrat we agree oh we got
the diva rip rip
she goes out the way she lived with
this Doritos in the back yeah where's
that Mountain Dew though
I just probably took it down there with
her
I like how the music is different
depending on the Rarity that you get
look at that is with a bucket head
bucket head Zenyatta
this is buried in the sand or something
and we got like 30 something more to go
okay epic oh what is that oh you got a
uh intro thing so there are intros oh
[__]
oh okay we did not go through the intros
I didn't even realize
uh that's pretty cool
I need that I I got I play a lot of
Reaper oh man
I really don't want to have to buy
crates later okay
I think I think all the Halloween stuff
has the uh like the moon or whatever
behind it right right yeah and the uh
bat whatever look at that
[Music]
this is this
I don't know it's all heroes it says
right like candy equip it sometimes it
has that weird bug thing or if you go
back out and back in it'll probably work
oh this thing of course of course
that Reaper intro though I agree guys I
hope you have voice line
trick or treat
oh God legendary
oh get wrecked and we got a freaking
dupe of the stupid Bastion apparently
somebody said there's a Genji skin there
wasn't right I don't we'll check after
yeah
because there's a Genji skin that's
gotta be pretty cool though
so far we've gotten two like legendaries
one was gold and one was like an old
skin which is really painful because you
usually only get about four okay another
one
there it is that's that's probably the
one I want the most roadhog the drunken
Stein monsters that one I don't play
roadhog enough but come on how can you
not with this he's the man I because I
can't play true tank so like I play
roadhog because he's like in the in
between yeah
people oh his stomach and this I love
this pipe going into it so good so good
so good all right
what number are we at oh
no wait there's a high level oh there's
Genji highlight intro
oh that is cool play it one more time
that's pretty cool nice all right maybe
that's what you guys were talking about
um that was pretty sweet okay I'm at 31
so we got about five more maybe okay oh
yeah we got a good amount okay Genji
Genji with a nice Victory pose
sure
all right
Heroes never die they just come back as
zombies
all right
[Music]
through what is this nothing it's a
victory pose yeah
chilling okay
[Music]
oh young Winston though
fine that's cool I like it you play
Winston a lot
the Tracer get a new skin no
but we got that Farah
I mean all things considered it's been
pretty good though I want to say the
event is out guys
um
so yeah you've opened half your boxes
we've already gotten like three epics
one legendary yeah so that's pretty good
you've netted like 1300 gold so I'm
halfway to uh yeah junkenstein it's
gonna be fine watch you got 26 boxes I
bet you you're gonna get it or get
enough gold I'm confident should we open
them now yeah do it let's keep going
just keep going let's let it all ride
right here got it right here right oh no
you know what okay this is the worst
feeling is getting a legendary dupe skin
you know why it's less than an epic skin
cost it's 200 coins why is it not 500 a
box of gold is 500 you should at least
get 500. that is you got two Tracer
voice lines as well
that is still one of my biggest pet
peeves about like opening boxes that is
like the one thing that happens yeah for
a dupe for a dupe legendary it's like
kind of ridiculous because it makes you
feel like oh I got legendary oh I got
200 gold I know that that the moment of
anticipation When You See It flying up
in the air and then when it just lands
and you're like I don't remember the the
fog on that I guess it I I kind of do
actually
oh you know what the reaper won't be
pretty cool to get too not peanut butter
yeah I think people are having cue
problems but just staying cute it's
pretty fast usually
hope tracers fine
scary yeah pretty typical
see you're only a thousand gold away
from buying the junkrat
because of all the duplicates I'm
getting
Hanzo Hanzo Victory pose yeah that's
fine it's fine
oh there's like a Reaper like uh candy a
candy yeah
City if you look at all the candy here
it's all uh all based off of characters
icons and stuff yeah up Lucio line
yep killed killed it
can you buy skins with coins yes it's
just three times the cost so legendaries
are three thousand epics or 750. it's
kind of ridiculous but it is what it is
uh symmetra that's all right
it's okay
we are running low
I want things
okay gold is good okay this is new oh
okay nice nice all right show
yes
really professional
equipped yeah we got to start a game
it's a bat right
it's supposed to be I think so yeah it's
kind of funny that it doesn't show but
that's cool I like it
we're inching our way to that junk up
no the duplicate
at least it's not a dupe oh there's a
mate there's a May intro it's a
highlighter oh okay
okay
that's pretty good I need that it's
called ice cream I need that
that's pretty good
you know what else I wish you could do I
wish you could like sell skins like like
a Marketplace like maybe that's too much
or trade skins to your friends
I guess no I would I wouldn't Advocate
selling them it's just gonna turn into
that yeah Counter-Strike kind of thing
but I would like to trade them like if
someone plays like one character a lot
and you're like okay I'll trade you that
skin for like one of your other ones or
like at least keep you can choose to
keep the duplicates if you want to to
trade them yeah yeah
22 200 coins won't be enough unless you
do the Epic we'll play the the new brawl
mode again in a second and then maybe
like one match with some like new skins
or something like competitive match and
then we'll see where we're at
all right so we've gotten two legendary
skins
um
new ones and then we got one dupe which
was very unfortunate but hey
that's pretty cool that's a good one you
got what 14 boxes I feel like you got a
good you got a good chance emo zarya
strikes again she always does man
which is Brew you need
800 gold to get your
oh man the dupes are real
someone making a comment there aren't
enough to trade yeah but I think to
Joey's point if you have dupes if you
traded your dupes away I think that's
not bad
but yeah but they wouldn't never do that
because then you'll never buy boxes yeah
there you go so it's all money thing
yeah it's a money thing let's be real
here
I mean they tried the wholesale stuff
with like Diablo and that kind of fell
on its face so
Mercy's gang yep oh
yeah you got it there we go you got it
uh we are winning we are winning
we are winning today that's three new
legendary skins he got the one he wanted
everything from here on out is just a
bonus it's just I mean we can hope for
the reaper one right here oh my God this
guy greedy greedy man so greedy
is there a Genji skin there is it's
pretty cool yeah it's cool I like it
those six
I'd be surprised if you got another
legendary I mean I wouldn't be shocked
but I'm pretty sure you're not gonna get
another one seven seven boxes I'm trying
to use reverse psychology
it's not working
oh you got a the Widow at least we're
getting most of the
pose I don't know I feel like I don't
know if it's just your luck
oh
oh that's our third one
um
but my luck like I said the first time
when I did uh
uh the summer games ones where it's
really awful like really compared to my
second set so I guess it's just RNG is
RNG
I think we're gonna get everyone's
Victory poses probably
and you've gotten a bunch of the new
highlight intros too so
more gold how much you're close you're
close to being able to buy just like
Reaper or like Reinhardt or whatever
are you guys playing OverWatch Lotto
heck yeah we are
we should go play the lotto I mean
considering how many of the Skins you
got
that's the old one
got two chances
come on nope
we got a new Winston angry Winston it's
good it's like Carrie all right last box
Moment of Truth Reaper or no Reaper
he's so sick if you got it no no didn't
think so
oh double honest stuff yeah are you
scared
yeah I'm scared all right it's pretty
funny so pretty fruitful only 250 away
you're at like what 400 so that was
pretty good 2300 gold uh was it four
legendaries or three four if you count
the dupe well you got two on top of that
too though right like you got the gothic
zarya you got the young Genji got the uh
Soldier well that wasn't uh legendary
though right yeah yeah so he got like I
think six legendaries total one dupe and
then two old ones and then three new
ones yeah there is no uh Genji Halloween
costume but he had the intro which you
have now which is the pumpkin carving
um
yeah
boom okay so let's go play another uh
game mode Let's go do that why don't you
try it on hard
okay let's see how it actually
equip the uh McCree
you had are you talking about
legendaries or what are you talking
about right now oh the Skins uh who's in
the uh oh right right okay so for all
yep uh Soldier
and then it's McCree
and who's the last one oh Hanzo yeah
there's you didn't get the Hanzo but you
could buy it don't do it don't do it
don't do it no we don't we don't yeah
I saw like this message the Windows 10
message restart required but it's gonna
do it outside of normal hours so let's
hope I was like don't do it right now we
need a delay for another like 15 to 30
minutes at least because we'll be on for
another like 20 30 minutes the update is
out Alpha mango it's available you can
play it
um but yeah we bought 50 crates I I feel
like we you you got what you wanted
which is the most important I don't feel
disappointed in this batch if we went
through 50 and we only got the like the
young Hanzo yeah then I would just feel
I feel definitely cheated yeah just play
someone that's not nice you know what's
that one's a little shady though because
that one's just like the desk because
like that is just a destiny but with a
different mask so well her gun's a
little different it's got webs too I
guess I guess all right here we go this
is hard yeah okay it's gonna be
toughen Steins thank you Patrice nurse
for uh going through that ad uh before
getting to watch his play uh we
appreciate your support I don't know
where if we're funny AF but we will try
or at least be mildly entertaining it
just comes naturally time to buy another
50 says justice cover I will not give
you an Activision 40 more dollars
of not our money
um
I don't know I mean like you got so many
of the ones like that you could get like
the only things we didn't get were like
Reinhardt
um Reaper
is that it I feel like oh
no there's way more stuff going on
and now you're the only healer Sans
Soldier they threw out those uh
Bombardier guys like really fast
that's still one of my favorite skins
that I don't have the uh the Hanzo wolf
oh it's so good because it just I like
that it changes the animation and it was
voice line too yep I would like to see
you know almost more of that like more
um changes in the oh no uh or door yeah
I'd like to see more changes with the um
with the actual like supers and stuff
like that there are some like junkrats
tires at least oh there's another
uh wheel coming from the left
wow it's got so much more life
and it killed that one guy
okay this is much harder than normal uh
I got Reaper but I want roadhog's new
skin yeah there we go
that's how they get you to keep playing
the game
but at least as you level you guys will
be getting new boxes and hopefully you
get what you want
if not you can always pay to look good
it's too far
where is the rest of my field
damage
can you sleep them
oh that's a good question probably I
feel like you can
oh of course
guys where are you
what they're like all hiding
oh they're dead that's why oh you guys
ripped
oh well
turns out hard is pretty hard
The
Defenders were slain oh that's cool I
like that that guy's one man
oh well here's this play of the game
that I helped out on oh that you gave
them the overboost
[Music]
I could use that a little bit later
why don't you uh do you want to try
again on heart or just one more on
normal or what
I'll try another one all right try
another one on hard
Bastion would work in this mode if they
let you use them but you can't use them
yeah these are the only four characters
I assume they they went through some
meticulous planning and figuring out
which one what was balanced yeah against
the the other four
um chars I think that's how you say your
name on the YouTube chat uh this is just
a new mode this is the new brawl mode
where you're pretty much
defending against junken Stein's Revenge
he's sending robots after you and his
compatriots you know Reaper Mercy
um junkrat himself
[Music]
but yeah
we are lucky we are in I know some
people are having Q issues or finding
game issues and stuff yeah do that look
at some hot skins and stuff oh game
found oh that was fast
Stein
[Music]
hopefully this will help because there's
a group of three with me oh nice
that's good
please be good please I mean you're the
damage dealer one of the damage dealers
at uh Charles again this is a new mode
that's out with an update it's available
for everyone it seems like it's out on
consoles as well just download it you
can play the mode for free you can buy
Halloween crates if you want to for some
new skins intros sprays all that good
stuff
um we got a bunch we just opened 51
because he leveled uh he netted out some
of the stuff he wanted got a good amount
of the skins and some of the intros
that'd be pretty cool
but yeah all of you guys can play that
right now I feel like I should be up
here
um gaming right now every time you level
you're just gonna get a Halloween crate
and you can't get the skins that way
um so you know there is still a way for
you to to get some of these new skins
it'll just be look at the draw oh geez
that Hanzo should go to that little spot
like I don't know I don't think he knows
it's all right I like that these guys
are being bold and playing hard off the
bat
the new update is on Console the hippo
Channel hippo Channel sorry
I think 76 is a vampire uh I know some
metros was labeled as a vampire I think
he's more of a zombie he's a zombie I
think it was called Immortal Immortal
okay so it could be either or
uh there's a tire to your right
man more life man everything's got more
life
that's pretty cool too to see soldiers
like all like tag like have like you
know oh another wheel
I have a cluster for it oh my God
all right well this is going about the
same as last time I feel like Hanzo is
holding on to his alt too though is the
problem
um but yeah you you live and you learn
with the uh with the hard mode we got
through normal pretty easily I feel like
or like it was fine right it was pretty
fair
I don't know uh Sombra is not out I'm
pretty sure she won't be out till
BlizzCon is my guess I could be wrong
but you know it feels like that's what
they're gonna do
although like Joey said there's been
some leaks you know if you don't want to
see the leaks don't do it if you're
curious I'm sure you could look up like
Sombra leaks on divorce I I didn't want
to do it actually but then I like I
clicked on the link oh you did not happy
about then why'd you do that
it was a link that said there seemed to
be a lot of somber links today and it
just showed a picture of every single
video thumbnail and it had the link in
there
oh what the hell uh Grammy
20505 mentioning yes is this man vs
machine from TF2 it essentially kind of
is right yeah that's cool yep Jacob
Johansson there is only four characters
that you can pick from
because uh so Muhammad the reason why
you probably can't choose your hero is
because like using a Bastion for this
would probably be op oh look at you
there we go I feel like it's always
Soldier because his alt is like yeah
maybe if you got this tire but yeah they
were fail or did I actually I'm not sure
I don't think you did because it
exploded like if you saw the the Hanzo
jump back I don't know maybe it felt
like he gave you credit that was a very
terrible play of the game
all right
um
you want to try hard again or you want
to just do a normal let's do a normal
one all right let's do a normal show
people yeah show people
uh what the whole uh brawl is and then
oh you could did you see that what
[Music]
what that yeah this is a Reaper yeah I
know but does he do that in the game
oh take his head off yeah I I don't
think so oh why is that not an emote
it is
how can you show that and then not have
that as part of the game he does have
yeah he has a highlight information oh
man
all right let's play some normal go find
a normal game
um competitive I'm not sure how much
time we have we have time I mean like I
think play when we're normal then we'll
do one competitive and then we'll get
out of here
no no do I uh do another jungle sign on
normal and then yeah yeah then then
we'll play competitive with some skins
or we can play quick play with some
skins or something
um
Louie Giff there I said your name feel
good
uh yeah mobile uh Mob style gameplay and
OverWatch would be pretty cool I want
more PVE stuff like this I think it'd be
fun I think it's it'd be it's a nice
change of pace for people to you know
stop like doing five E fives I mean
brawls are good but having these kind of
brawls I think is an interesting kind of
twist to what they have in the lineup
yeah
um just checking for any uh new like
other things that I might miss like
highlight intros
s open more crates uh probably won't be
opening more crates unless it's on my
account no I'm just kidding
um but yeah we'll see I I don't think
we're opening more crazy we opened 50.
it's a pretty good amount and we got and
he got what he wanted yeah like it'd be
different if he didn't get it because
then that would trigger you to want to
buy more boxes right but then he got
what he wanted so I think this is great
I need that I need that uh highlighter I
like it
I wish her skins were better I don't
think her Skins are that great like for
her like what you could do with it I
guess she got she has a firefighter one
and then like the Himalayan one yeah
I think you'll be fine for this
die devil
he just said can we please win this this
is not even that hard
yeah well on medium is not that bad but
you never know
s
Dino Jake saying Left 4 Dead style Co-op
missions would really suit OverWatch
yeah maybe
we'll see I'm sure they got stuff in the
pipes I mean like who knows I've I've
enjoyed every one of the event uh type
of style games I haven't played this but
I could tell that this is something I
would have fun playing with my friends
with the thing is though I'm not sure if
something like this will would be able
to last like you know years down the
line yeah yeah yeah they would need to
have some maybe something a little bit
more random scale yeah yeah I think it
would have to be almost like layers like
on this map it's like oh you got past
the first like tier now you're moving on
to the next part and then there's like
more stuff different stuff going on like
maybe even I mean they could easily lend
um or like gain something from like wow
raids and stuff like that right like
where you know you're going through
through like a map there's like like
different scenarios environmental
changes where you guys all have to move
together communicate but you know for a
brawl like this and for like no commute
like lack of communication and stuff you
can't make it too complex yeah you know
NJ man said your name what's up
the Rune dog who needs stats when you
walk can watch an OverWatch live stream
thanks for tuning in man appreciate it
this reminds me of Team Fortress 2 man
versus the machine it probably really
does Frozen uh frosted coins
can I set it right
I gotta buy a bunch of boxes says pissed
hashirama senju I'd be pissed too if I
was hashirama
you know he just wanted to be friends
with you know Madara and stuff but
Madara had to have his own way sorry got
Anime there
there is no Genji skin there is a Genji
uh nice grenade if you got that um there
is a Genji uh player intro which is
pretty cool he carves a pumpkin
um
yeah there's some nice little like
nuggets that we didn't know about that
we got from the boxes those are the best
surprises I think yeah
hello choco Berry gaming
uh it is out on Console we're playing on
PC
uh Justin early I don't know what the
balance changes were added in this uh I
didn't look up patch notes I was I just
was more concerned with the fact that
the Halloween stuff was out so
unfortunately I don't have the answer to
that question sorry
the president
try to sleep on this time okay
he's gonna teleport down to where I am
someone's telling you got more headshots
good thing you can't get headshots oh
you can't put him asleep put tea bag
yeah all right mission complete
oh God damage please take care of them
you have sleep Dart again if you need to
oh yeah of course
I wonder if he actually uh oh he doesn't
do damage to the door which is good
is the mode on Console yes it is Caesar
pokerist don't worry that's what we're
here to help you with
um I don't think the download Stupid
someone said four gigs
um but some people are having problems
with uh downloads Subway brings up a
good point actually Kakashi Hatake
anyways he says how come there's no Van
Helsing I'm a creep that's a pretty good
that's a pretty good question that just
seems like right up your alley actually
that's a fun game to play okay chat like
think of all the you know creative
combinations of skins that we didn't see
for the characters that are in the game
so like Van Helsing McCree seems like a
very
you know straightforward thing that they
could easily did but you know
I guess that just was one that maybe
slipped by the wayside or something they
just have enough time for it yeah
because whenever they do these events
even though they've only got a couple of
them even though they've only done a
couple of events like this they've only
given the major skins to maybe like a
handful of Heroes I think they just want
to face them out a little bit yeah I
mean they're giving each character like
at each character but like a set of
characters some love I feel like each
kind of like thing so like last time it
was Tracer zarya Lucio
um and you know there's a bunch of also
epic skins but in terms of legendaries
and I think uh each time they want to
have like probably a course set of like
you know four or five maybe six of their
um Heroes to get like legendaries and
stuff like that
um
we can show off the Skins again right
before we stop uh we'll play a little
bit more uh there is no Genji skin
uh werewolf McCree it's High Noon that's
pretty good
uh sexy nurse Tracer okay it could be
sexy anything at that point right
Halloween costumes and everything oh
nice
Devil May
oh they could have did like um they
could have did like a no hassenko from
dark Sockers I wonder if they could have
did something like that for me but that
doesn't fit the theme right she's
definitely gonna be part of the winter
theme or whatever so
um
scream for Genji
uh Diva did not get a skin unfortunately
I don't even think she got an intro
uh she only got uh the like everyone got
the um player pose with the graveyards
shout out to Itachi and yeah
Devil May Cry werewolf Winston
but he's a but he's a boy right harambe
harambe
he's like he has like he has a gorilla
suit on as well oh uh The Mysterious Mr
Quinn says the soldier 76 skin is based
off of Michael Jackson's outfit from
Thrillers oh that yeah
see that oh that was the wrong person
it's okay Hanzo can go crazy
man here's his alt like really quickly
he must be just scattering all day
uh Sombra has not been revealed uh
Terminator Genji
pumpkin Diva well they did pumpkin with
Reaper I think that was uh more fitting
to be honest like uh Jack the Reaper
Jack the Reaper I don't know I just said
that even though that's not a thing but
that would have worked
it's Jack there wait
um
the rock the Sleepy Sleepy Hollow is
that what it is
foreign
pirate junkrat well it's not a pirate
right now they could have did that for
speak like a Pirate Day Bigfoot Winston
pretty good uh Reinhardt did get one
it's kind of cool it's just kind of like
his old face but he's got like this fire
tint glow to his uh to his head pretty
good actually
you know I kind of wish there was more
of a reason to scope as Anna other than
like healing from far away because
there's no reason otherwise you're just
always like hip firing I mean the only
thing is that it's it's a hit scan's
projectile but it's not gonna make that
much of a difference
yeah yeah is this on PS4 yes haunted
Samurai Genji that sounds pretty good
actually
servants never die okay so I guess you
could sleep her or kill her right like
that's before she died
I think it's a regular robot
guys
should save that oh
I think they're aiming for uh Mercy
which is good
nice
I don't know I feel like he wasted his
alt there
don't die please don't die
oh no they killed Hanzo though
I think they got yeah they got Mercy
which is oh my God
oh junkrats just spewing bombs like he
would in a normal game
I would just focus on Frankie
that's good sleep dark
no you're good
wait a second what is this uh this is
the Halloween event for OverWatch
um a lot of people are saying this is
reminding them of Man Against the
Machines from TFC it does definitely
guy keeps stealing please oh no okay
okay we got Itachi is still alive he's
still freaking happy magician Genji
[Music]
here's the reference for 76 Jackson
of course yeah I don't know how I didn't
think about that I I don't know I don't
know I didn't either but then he should
have just had the uh he should have had
like his his uh player intro should have
been like beat it or not or you know
Thriller sorry Thriller
you know what I really like about the uh
the end here everyone will get a card
because there's only four of us so at
least you know what you did that's why
PVE is good for most people man it you
know some hopes to show but for me yeah
uh all right why don't you play like a
normal match with some of your six skins
and then we'll kind of wrap it up from
there
are you close to leveling at all I think
you should just quick play in case where
am I at no no McCree huh they changed
this UI huh I like this McCree and
junkrat oh die Devil he's like oh we won
one finally you know what I played 14
hours of McCree when the game first came
out before they nerfed them and then I
still haven't good though I know but the
people that I played after that they
still haven't even reached that and I
haven't I've hardly played them in the
last like three months
all right
Lewis pancake saying we need a Hanzo
skin yeah
I don't even play Hanzo that much but I
agree with that oh he has the uh the
Dead one the zombie one yeah the demon
I think it's pretty cool actually we
didn't get that one either actually so
uh why don't you oh you are human nice
nice
there is no scan for Tracer
unfortunately guys
I don't think we missed we don't play
league or I don't do you play league no
I follow League a little bit but I don't
play TSM TSM right
Bastion for the win oh no
show them that uh the bat the little
bats that he makes with his feet oh the
emote
though
uh F-16 missile when is this out this is
out already you can get it Skeleton King
Genji
cross slow a little cross promotion
there now
uh Shane got the reaper screen grabs on
that Mia's gonna get a Santa outfit for
Christmas I think so
You could argue that roadhog could maybe
get a Santa should get like an elf one
maybe like a t-us Hannah skin would be
hilarious actually
oh yeah play is uh yeah there we go lock
it in before someone else tries to take
it from you then you feel bad
can you buy them are they somewhere
games only in crates you can buy them
but they're three times the cost so epic
Skins are 750 uh legendary skins are
three thousand so if you have three
thousand smackaroos and you really want
a skin you can do that but uh that's the
equivalent of three legendary skins
pot is there a Bastion skins yes there
is a like rest in peace rip one
um he can show you that later
uh it's not that special in my opinion
but you know if you play fashion at
least you get a skin
he's like Made of Stone or something
like that
let's see all those highlight intros we
will uh like at the end of the stream
after this quick play match I'll have
Joey go through as much as he can
remember one last time so you guys can
see it
um but yeah
Road dog or Reinhardt was gonna be Santa
yeah you see that
when will they go the loot boxes we
already did that script gaming if you
scrub back we opened 50.
um so you can check that out it's about
in the middle of the Stream
uh-oh oh he's got the Frank oh here your
creation killed you
oh yeah
Josh about uh Vogues I think sorry if I
butchered your last name there are a
couple Reapers got a skin or uh sorry
Reaper's got player intro May's got one
um Genji's got one there's a couple
there's couple cool ones
Nerf Mei Maze My Bae though man GameSpot
is PSN down don't know we're playing on
PC
you can do that uh his PSN down on
Google sometimes that works
uh please try not to spam subscriptions
I really would appreciate that guys and
me too especially
oh no
no yep may all day
play with zarya we're probably not gonna
play zarya because she doesn't have a
new skin granted we did get her one of
her legendary skins
uh May got a player intro it's like uh
ice cream or something or was that yeah
it's called ice cream
you gotta kill your creation
for defying you
oh God where are you coming from
oh you got someone
Hanzo does have a skin it's like a demon
um like zombie oh god of course
the demon zombie version it's pretty
cool actually he's like uh dark gray
colored
again just want to say uh thank you
everyone for watching if you haven't
already uh followed us on Twitch hit
that follow button so you can get
updated for whenever we go live and
subscribe on YouTube
um because that would uh greatly help us
and it'll uh help you guys know when
things are going on you know will you
get anything with your new junkrat yep
there we go oh we got it we got a Korean
as well I don't know what that said
uh
it's kind of cool nah this is quick play
man don't you know
oh you're so dead no
Reinhardt just going through no problem
Vera bat
oh my
uh May does not have a new skin
oh you got the point okay here comes the
epic comeback
um yeah I mean luckily at least the
micro transactions in this game haven't
affected gameplay that's my biggest
peeve of microtransactions so if it's
just paid to look good it is what it is
you can do that if you want to or you
can attain them really slowly
um it's all just uh appearance
no cure burn skin this time around oh no
oh man that guy uh this uh Frankenstein
is really is really getting you
um not having a good look
just like what have you done to me
uh he could try playing Mercy or someone
after we do we did get the mercy skin or
roadhog we'll see what the the lineup
looks like
oh I think your whole teams though
they're contesting well there can oh no
you almost have all you can run away
okay last ditch effort oh of course what
oh they killed it yeah
all right first round failed okay
zayson uh yes the Halloween event is
online
there is no sexy nurse Derek Minor I'm
sorry
after the Tracer semi-debacco I don't
think there's gonna be sexy anything
new Dead pharah
Mighty gyro there are um new skins for
characters that didn't get skins from
the summer games like uh we've kind of
discussed earlier it's like I think
they're trying to you know give sets of
characters some love each time around
uh JS per asking the question do you
like the update like I really like it
yeah
uh I I'm with you I'm I'm pretty I like
that kind of man Against the Machine
mode you can play pharah too oh we
already have a soldier okay fine no
mercy or you can double heal yeah just
like competitive mode nobody believes in
double heal but that's what wins games
that's what wins games don't have a
Healer
yeah you're good probably gonna die
watch out for the genders
you need Frozen
visit online for PS4 yes you just need
to uh get into their lucky mix new
subscriber thank you for subscribing
oh God it's that same guy swishing
McCree oh did he he's after me again
hey man he knows who to go after we will
show the skins and whatnot Gavin as the
last thing we do in the Stream don't
worry
so uh Hubble oh sorry hob I can't say
your last name it's too hard you can buy
the skins with your old currency it just
costs three times as much so it's not
impossible to uh buy any of the stuff if
you had pre-existing gold but it costs
like 3 000 for new legendaries there's a
new Reinhardt right there that's 750.
the epics are three times so 250 times
three is 750.
um but yeah you can't buy them
oh crap oh no where's your team
oh
oh Swank Swank
a good healer can totally sell yeah
that's true but I think it's easier with
two healers because then if your healer
gets soloed and even if your team is
good at keeping like having a May next
to her it's probably better still to
have two because you know having a Lucio
for overshield and stuff like that is
like all the utility that you get from
having
I guess yeah of course
did they update rank icons
um they did they did so they look a
little bit a little bit cleaner now
and they also um I think when
in the main menu they also look a lot
it's a little bit different yeah and you
said the UI was a little bit different
as well so it looks like the change of
surprise or the the patch is
surprisingly bringing a lot of new
changes to not just the game but oh no
update uh is out on Console you do get
Halloween boxes on level up
um trying to read questions and stuff
like that what's our favorite Halloween
skin uh for you is junk fat right yeah
uh which is the Frankenstein one um for
me probably Reaper or roadhog the
Frankenstein both are pretty pretty cool
uh characters I play as well usually
that's how how we gravitate
um you can unlock the Skins after you
update it's just a matter if you have
the goal to buy it or sorry the coins
whatever or if you just buy boxes you
can buy boxes
um Kyle kawakami thank you for your
subscription
um again yes it is out on consoles winch
junk signs Revenge uh well like are we
talking about literally it could be any
time really uh but it's out actually now
if you want to just play it
um
yeah sorry if I keep saying it's out of
consoles people just keep asking I'll
let chat answer that question from now
on do we like the new brawl I think it's
uh I think it's novel it's interesting
hard mode was pretty tough when we were
playing it or when Joey was playing I
was just watching of course oh my God
man that guy knows what to do
um
I think you what are your thoughts on
the uh the junkenstein's Revenge I think
it's good I don't think it's something
like people avoid asking like about uh
the brawl modes to stay permanent that's
like one of the main things like for I
think Lucille Ball people were like oh
this should be like a permanent thing
and yeah
in a lot of ways that makes sense to
have like different modes but
as a holiday thing but not as permanent
mode yeah unless they flush it out more
like as it stands right now it seems
kind of simplistic yeah it's pretty
basic in terms of like what it is and
once you play it and beat it you have a
general gist I mean hard mode does add
that extra flavor but like you said I
think once you beat hard mode there
probably isn't too much to go back for
unless uh you know you're playing with
your friends or something so we we both
like it but the sustainability I think
the week for it is good you know for
brawl and whatnot is like
it's a good timing in terms of like how
long it's Gonna Last yeah
[Music]
there is not a tracer skin unfortunately
um
[Music]
um you need to buy boxes or you have to
use pre-existing old gold or level up
and get boxes you will get uh the new
Halloween boxes we'll play a couple like
another match or something he has more
skins uh someone's telling you to go
roadhog Okay so
um of course you know every OverWatch
player would ideally be good at every
character but you know I'm sure Joey has
his strengths and weaknesses so don't
judge too hard because like I probably
would I would be bad at Mercy just so
you know and I'd be decent at Roadhouse
um
but yeah
all righty yeah get that freaking yeah
cause you got to pull them into the into
the the pit yeah
do we have any suggestions on zarya's
new skin says Sarah Jameson I don't know
actually and I don't know if she'll get
one that soon because she got one for
the summer games which was a pretty cool
one like the the weightlifting one
um there's been some other characters
that haven't gotten new skins like Hanzo
hasn't gone one like wouldn't be shocked
if he gets one may hasn't gotten one so
you know I'm sure that like if there is
a winter event Christmas event I'm sure
some of those characters will probably
be getting legendaries she might get an
epic who knows
how much do Halloween skins cost it
depends uh as I had mentioned earlier
750 and 3000.
the uh uh the OverWatch uh Halloween
expansion is free so you can get that
um
hi uh mighty chair asking are the crates
three regular items in one Halloween
it's totally random you can get like
three Halloween one old
um you can get you know like any
combination of something you know like
that it could be anything really a few
roadhogs is yeah it's not as necessary
the worst thing you can always heal
yourself is that the one that kept
killing you I feel like is he
uh is it another or something yeah oh he
says hi see I think those name is red
but it could be him too please show us
the new highlight intros we'll do that
at the end we're gonna play like maybe
one at least this match if not another
one new Mercy skins three thousand if
you don't uh get it from the thing oh we
should have hooked them out of that
whoops
yeah okay terrible at Rojo that's all
right
Reaper for next uh we can play Reaper
it's just that he doesn't have the skin
for it so it's oh yeah nice hook yeah
there you go
oh where the hell is your dealer
healer's telling you to heal yourself
my healing went off just not not fast
enough
the soul of very brief the Zenyatta skin
should have just been a white sheet over
him with a ghost face on it with a
marker with him floating that would have
been great
actually uh it probably wouldn't have
like looked as nice as they wanted it to
look but it's pretty good I liked it all
right Winston oh my God okay yeah I
forgot that like originally when I was
playing roadhog I switched the uh
is that a Reaper
nice
heals it heals it
get out of here oh come on
trying to help you tell you to heal
first because he only had like 150 life
hero
um
shoot out them sprays more and more we
got some sprays shoot that spray out
every time you kill someone oh you don't
have a new one on him
how long will the boxes be there I'm not
sure how long the Halloween event would
be so it's subject to that probably
probably like what is it like a week or
two no I think it's something
November 1st yeah there you go through
Halloween I'm an idiot
okay yeah I need to stop
it's all right it's all right getting
used to it thank you for the tip there
Iverson
got it got her bad chats cats usually
got her back appreciate everyone again
for watching and chatting having a fun
time
oh oh it's okay you kind of pushed him
away that was weird or Lucio did
Siri
are we streaming the new Call of Duty
beta says Emerald we actually are uh I
believe we might have it Thursday maybe
or Friday I forget the exact date but
look out for that if you guys subscribe
to our Channel you'll get an update once
we create that event uh when we go live
with it but we will be doing that and I
believe someone also mentioned uh this
week might be early access for
Battlefield one so if that is the case
which I think it is we'll also be doing
that so stay tuned for that uh thank you
for asking that question Christmas
Alfonso
oh my you're so good
uh I hope that didn't eat your alt yeah
maybe half sometimes zero really um that
sucks
oh they're contesting hard
but they did push in with the Lucio Alt
do you have a torbjorn
um let's see
let's see uh oh yeah I guess there's
also Leonardo watch that freaking anime
actually cool to see some anime people
in here um saying uh remember to log in
to get your free Halloween crate I think
you do get one for free so
I I wasn't sure if we actually got one
for free because he bought 50 and then
also nice hook
um and then we got one from him leveling
hey this triple tank comp is working
I like it High Noon though I see him oh
you got hooked nice
Reinhardt Santa yep dude I'm telling you
Reinhardt would get gets all the skins
oh
stay away
oh this is the old to them did he yeah
what a waste
The Headless Horseman Reaper I I wish we
got that that would be one that I want
Reaper and roadhog nice
oh yeah kill the mercy nice
probably here yeah don't mind me
backseat driving how much does 50 loot
crates cost 40 I believe
it's one of those things where like the
more you buy the more you're gonna get
the more you buy the more you save yeah
so we would be uh
fools not to buy 50 right
I guess so
I'd like more country themed skins like
UK USA yeah well they kind of did that
for the Olympic Games I mean they pretty
much had like most of the characters got
like some type of a thing most of the
skins
Mr X3 production getting that Reaper
skin congrats on that
thanks Leonardo watch he says he's a
little jealous that we got awesome skins
I would hope that if you spent uh forty
dollars that you would get some awesome
skins because
that's uh that's like a DLC or almost a
full price game at that point so I'll
say hi to you ale benonati what rip the
monies I agree
how much for 24. I forget I think 20.
yeah I think that's that sounds about
right actually
do
it
I'm gonna stalk them here nice just be
careful not to get punted off oh what
happened he got punched it off right
go get that yeah wow that was a one shot
I said she probably already took damage
put it no it said you get a hundred
oh don't let Diva push you off either
get over here oh what
beautiful
how long will the boxes be there uh
until the update's done which is I think
November 1st
good luck Leonardo watch if you do spend
40 I hope you get the skin that you want
or skins
made the OverWatch rngs disguise forever
be with you
get over here
seriously
hide in the corner and E
h
that's your alt which is good
I love these updates love the Skins yeah
I think both of us here agree with that
statement
or does she feel like I'm getting
messaged about something there is no
Winston skin unfortunately Tinkerbell
sorry yeah I somehow got that guys very
much let me just make sure no one from
work is hitting us up
in case
I don't think that's the case we are
good
oh watch out
you got Ultra spoil yeah
punch some people like off the map oh
there's only one person
oh where'd you go no she died
five bucks says he charges oh pharah
trying to push you off
oh
my God that range though
you better heal and bogging the Curtis
saying I bought boxes but my parents
said only 24 not 50. you gotta you gotta
sell them as I'm getting six or more
boxes
hey he's gonna go with you
oh no
you got to tell them it's a it's more of
a bargain it's like when you used to go
to the arcade and you're like hey Mom
five dollars gets me 24 coins but if we
put 10 in there we're getting 50 coins
that's an extra six coins and they're
like oh you know what you're right
usually that doesn't work oh man Reaper
just got a quad
okay I'm gonna wait how long have we
been playing oh they got the point wow
they're gonna try the big comeback
um
before I finish this one and then we'll
see and then we'll probably just show
off the skins and intros and stuff like
that and probably call it a day
but again do appreciate you guys all
tuning in you can like subscribe follow
and all that stuff
out from the skies
you have your alt still
toast made you toast
this is actually that that's that
capture is a good spot for me
as well
yeah Reaper spotting into get a die die
die play of the game My Favorite have
you seen gendry's Victory pose mini
ninja we have we have it actually we uh
we were able to procure it
justice could use a little nap that was
probably the best yeah
nice did you guys win win then or you
gotta get third one here no that was it
I keep thinking competitive mode that's
why come on Uncle fuzz did you play the
game no it wasn't me at least I don't
think so I know it was toast yeah of
course let's watch this uh die die
yep seems about right oh and he got
[Music]
yeah at least I wasn't there
seems about right all right Joey why
don't you
um show them some of those hot skins and
stuff like that that was a great
awesome round there
and uh yeah he's gonna try to go through
as many skins and weapons and intros and
all that stuff
uh that he can remember and that I can
remember here we'll just get rid of
ourselves and you can just straight up
see it there we go even better all right
go no HUD I like it says Anna's and then
her gun
it's nice little orange and black
Spider-Man sort of
and down see uh all the characters if
you haven't seen already they have the
tombstone Victory pose
yeah and so they'll all be uh dead in
some form here yeah there's a couple
good ones though I feel like yeah Diva
one's good with the Doritos in the back
and and uh I think that's it for her
right yeah she's got the we got that
so it's pretty nice or if you like Stone
colored characters ah the rip is cool
but it sucks that you don't see it in
that form it's only when he's standing
and like how much how often are you
actually doing this and you don't see uh
the bird either as much yeah it's a crow
Victory pose yeah just his head and the
and the crow on top
he still works man he still works
don't think he has any other ones yeah
Diva I think I don't even know she has
anything she just has this and then
she's got the Doritos in the back right
you said yep yeah a couple Doritos
saving those for later
no highlighter doesn't have anything
Genji does have his not a skin sorry but
he has this uh cool uh
uh Victory pose and then he also has the
um really cool intro
I'm so jealous you have that that skin
he still has some of the best highlight
intros in my opinion him in like
Zenyatta they're really good
emotes nope we can show you Hanzo but
he's got not much uh he's got one skin
which is a demon one pretty cool I guess
I like it I don't play enough Hanzo
though
um unfortunately this weapon is pretty
much the same right we we determined
Yeah it's red yep
emotes no emotes doesn't look like
it's got the victory pose with Jason
arrows
gray oh you got those the sprays would
be too hard for us to go through so you
guys can just check those out yourself
of course we got the one you wanted the
most
show the weapon too
nice little subtle touches and it's got
like the little atom or whatever on the
front
my baby
uh
but he's got a victory pose just his leg
and a trap oh and he's got the Tesla
wheel on the back which is cool and that
one changes basically or well I would
assume the leg and the wheel change
depending on who yeah which skin you got
on which is cool there's no skin for
Diva unfortunately guys
Lucio I didn't even I don't think we
even went through Lucille I think he's
got that there's a couple of voice lines
too but I can't remember who has them so
it's like hard yeah killed it is a
Halloween one yeah
for him McCree
he doesn't have any yeah this one yeah
no highlighters
May's got me he got the highway intro
here
I like it
it's a good one
and that thing kind of looks like a
little bit like the Pac-Man ghosts a
little bit
by Reaper he doesn't have enough coins
to buy reefer I need 250 more I think I
have 3 000 on mine I might just buy a
Reaper I don't know we'll see
that's pretty good I like it
the uh Victory pose Mercy did get a skin
the witch
pretty cool and the broom yep that's
also really cool I like that
and then what was her weapon oh looks
looks made of wood or something yeah
like the broom pretty much
I don't think she got anything there
yeah that's all she got did she get a
victory pose
oh yeah that's right
jazz
R.I.P
you got the wings on here too and same
with uh pharah she's got skin too though
but oh wow that's really cool now that
you have that skin yeah it's all glowy
yeah got the wings on the tombstone and
the helmet
and what I wish you could do I wish you
could zoom in on these yeah like after
you get them you can see them the
weapon's not too different which is a
little bit unfortunate
we'll show roadhog soon enough don't
worry we're going through all of them
this is yeah this I gotta get that I
might pay for that I might just pay for
it I mean I mean I'm sorry I have 3 000
gold I think I might just buy it it
looks like it's worth it it's like I
bought that one Reinhardt skin from the
last uh update with the new map because
it was like too cool
it's got the candle lights too man you
got a pumpkin jack-o-lantern inside the
gun sound is going in and out I hope
it's just for you nobody else has made
that comment but hopefully it's just for
you
he's not even dead just just climbing
out he's like I'm Not Dead
he's highly intro oh this is great
surprise
Harry Townsend we're probably done
playing you can scrub back through the
rest of the VOD we played a couple of
the new brawls this is pretty cool too I
actually might buy this one yeah it's
pretty good
um we played a couple of matches in the
brawl the new bra and we also played a
couple just uh quick play matches with
some skins and stuff like that so
fortunately we're probably done in terms
of playing we're just showing off the
rest of this stuff because people wanted
to see it
someone a lot of people saying I thought
McCree was gonna get a Van Helsing but I
know it's it's it's perfect for him but
yeah there is roadhog's new skin pretty
sweet got a new gun and a new hook
you don't come to think of it he is the
only character that you can play in the
brawl that doesn't have a new skin
Uh Oh you mean McCree yeah yeah but you
can you can play as a soldier Anna and
Hanzo they all they all have one except
yeah mccree's just forgotten about
saving it for later
big enough that the hand is almost as
big as the tomb
there's no highlight intro
soldiers got a new skin we found out
from chat thank you chat that it's
supposed to be like Michael Jackson's
Thriller
um you can show the skin too and the
weapon I guess yeah look at that it's
pretty has a little face on the back
down
James Mesko shout out to you there you
go uh yep symmetra's got a vampire uh
skin got the bats on the stockings
essentially and just everything is like
kind of red
yeah her teleporter changes color as
well is just
it would have been cool like I said
earlier to have like a different
animation on the portal but oh well
uh which gravestone skin do you think is
best Chappelle Chappelle asks I like
Reapers
uh because he's like crawling out like
he's not actually dead what was
torbjorn's oh yeah a lot of them are
just like a hand coming out yeah so
Genji's had the like little um like
Dragon yeah spinning around it I think
widowmakers is actually pretty funny
looks like this yeah she got the the
mine is on there too
so yeah I know Widowmaker skin but I
mean like that Countess version already
in a way is like you know
that's all right to me it's kind of
boring yeah
no skin for her yeah
he got an intro too oh no he had a emote
oh is it any Mozart yeah
show it on the ground so they can see
that this is spider or I think it's
supposed to be like a bat but it looks
like a spider though
spiders don't have like but look at it
like how far his fingers are apart like
a bat you know what I mean I don't know
interpret it how you will bird of some
sort
zarya didn't get a skin either or she
got anything don't forget a rest in
peace she's got this every every single
character R.I.P yeah
no Sombra guys no Sombra uh Zenyatta did
get a uh skin it's okay I think it's
cool but
I wouldn't pay 750 for it I like the the
painted uh the skeleton guy Voodoo
almost
even though Zenyatta is one of my guys
they kind of they like buffed him really
good and then they nerfed him a little
bit Yeah brought them back down to earth
I guess because he's too good
was that it oh the rest in peace oh hey
the somehow the the balls are still dead
yeah
yeah that's it yeah I think that's it
all right let's uh wrap this up
all right well thank you Joey for
playing and and uh showcasing the new
Halloween event and also getting a
chance to open boxes I now know why
everyone out there was jealous when I
opened boxes because it feels good to
have 50 boxes you're just watching me
wishing that that was yours it's okay
because you didn't get Reaper that would
have that one would have hurt me the
most but you got roadhog so I'm a little
bit torn but I'm also happy you got the
one you want on it which is the junkrat
one which is ultimately all you can ask
for is like really getting the one you
want but um yeah thanks again Joey
and I want to say thank you to all the
uh people watching on Twitch YouTube
games watch chat I tried to we tried to
rather answer as many questions as we
could the update is now available
console and PC you can play it the
Halloween boxes again will be available
until I think the first correct yeah and
the update itself until the first
November the first sorry pretty sure
yeah yeah um so go ahead and play that
it's free uh you can earn those boxes
from just leveling and playing uh or you
can buy boxes totally up to you but uh
stay tuned at two o'clock we got the
lobby uh we'll be on real briefly uh I
at least I think I will be to talk about
OverWatch a little bit more and then
also some other stuff as well so stay
tuned at two o'clock that's in about an
hour and a half uh if you want to and
then stay tuned later in the week I
think we do have a cloud beta infinite
Warfare beta stream as well as I think a
battlefield one Early Access multiplayer
stream so yeah that's about it thank you
again Joey thanks for having me thank
you everyone uh hopefully gerk's outro
works